you're going to do everything in your
power to get there you come here's that
grind it's that hunger to get until you
go my main thing is always being myself
no sleep no dance-off there's just so
much hard work
hello lusatian my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word in believe it I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you in your journey today we're
going to learn from actor and rapper
Joey badass and my face on his top 10
success rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which ones
you guys like the best and as always as
you're watching issues something that's
pretty resonance with you please leave
it in the comments below so folks around
other people can be inspired I print a
prize as well and also when you write it
down much more likely to stick for
yourself as well
enjoy
my advice to people is to follow your
heart you know not as for anybody is
saying to you about a dream or night day
that you have if you really feel like
customer you know I'm talking more like
that good that deep that rich like I can
do that or I can do this just do it
learning I would like to live honestly
that might be the test of your life I
might be the test of this turn everybody
has to change to jump you have a choice
to general and whenever sometimes you
got to make that job I thought I doesn't
want to make the jump you know I'm
saying you don't want to live your life
thinking like damn I should've jumped
back 20 years ago
okay years ago I could have been that
friend I would have been what had been
different but the things you would never
know because we never took everything to
take the risk I want to put people in
the mas state that I have because I
think that Israel healthy one to keep
you something I think is real what you
said the mind state that I have what is
that - claim is real beneficial so I
think you know this society pivot to
mankind and like with this current I
will be filming like you know what the
message that I'm currently trying to
push the the concept of like you know
this whole picture is basically you know
I'm working I'm welcoming people to this
before the money monster and what that
really is is like you know that before
the money monster is that time where you
right before you realize are like you
know you got this goal you got these
things that you want to do and at that
moment where you realize that you know
you're going to do everything in your
power to get there you some is that
grind it's that hunger to get until your
goal and even once you get there is all
about keeping that mind state like you
know like even me right now like you
know I feel like I've attained so much
I came so far but I'm stealing that
before the money monster like I still
got that same ground as if I was just
like you know still rapping in school
like that you feel me
you know I want people to apply that to
life no matter what there goes our like
you know if they want to be a doctor
like you know what's in a being that
before the money monster of it like you
I trained you in passion well yeah and I
just want people to always relive that
and like you
live with that every day I've also seen
comparisons to tonigth illmatic you know
times and what what type of pressure
does that put on you if any or maybe
inspiration yeah or inspiration if
anything it drives me to not sound like
that okay you know yeah it drives me to
be myself because you know the
comparisons are great they're always
great and you know is an honor to be
compared to like somebody like Nadia and
illmatic yeah great immense body of work
yeah hold on
you know my main thing is always beating
myself up a sound-alike myself I don't
want to sound like anyone I want people
to be like yo you sound like Joey we
became the change that we wanted to see
slowly like that's what we started
growing to and you know progressing
towards when I basically grew up and I
got older you know even when you see
movies as a child and you grow up and
you watch it again you understand it
differently you know you see different
things about that was pretty much the
same case with music for me you know
when I got older and then I revisited
these things and everything it was just
like it hit me like an epiphany again
and everything and and identified that
as what rapper really is you know what
that that's that's traditional right for
me you feel me and basically when I
started you know making 1999 when we
formed forever in 2011 2012 what we
realized in the game like you know what
we loved about hip hop so much we didn't
see in the game so we basically decided
to become the change that we wanted to
see what's your success what's your
what's your secret I mean you know the
game change as soon as the internet came
around even the internet I know what it
did for me it would cut out the
middleman I didn't have to you know go
out physically and you know me somebody
an offer from a label listen my INR was
YouTube you put in my videos up you know
I'm saying and sending it to worldstar
and hoping it get picked up which
eventually did way after just you know
the fans are who you know got me
traveling overseas you know and I'm
saying the fan
who got me playing on the TV playing on
the radio so yeah and I think is is
extremely important is extremely
imperative to you know give back to
those people and you know make sure that
that that they're they're happy they're
you know not not just content but
they're you know elated
from like you know what you're giving
them and also like you know these people
are inspired by me so I just do the best
that I can to you know keep uplifting
them and to show them like it with it
just like me and same way I follow my
dreams why can't you two how difficult
has a journey been in the four years
that people don't like get to see oh
there's a lot of late nights early
mornings you know there's a lot of it's
this little sleep I shouldn't say like
that just like you know absolutely no
sleep no days off there's just so much
hard work you know it's never really
especially for a god like me like I'm
such a hard-working like I don't know
I'm gonna tell people that don't know
how to relax
I don't know how to chill out you know
like even if I wanted vacation like I'm
still trying to find a way to work I
already know the energy and the passion
and you know just the truth that I put
into my music so it's like I don't need
people to validate that for me you know
what I mean so so and and and that's
that comes from me being at a level
where I just want to be content with
everything I do stuff I already know
what I'm putting into my work is like I
don't need to be wrapped up about what
I'm trying to get out of get out or get
back from it it's like you know I mean
I'm just here to do this you know I mean
and and yeah that's what it is it's like
don't don't worry to be a you know it is
a quote I can't remember who said it but
it's basically like don't strive for
recognition just be worthy of it you
know that means there's something alone
most on you
yeah you can't live your life waiting
for validation from people because it
you always be miserable at that point it
just it's it's never like my happiness
is determine you is is outside of me
yeah this is
would be that way I think they are I
think oh you know is a interesting thing
to watch me grow you know what I'm
saying on I tend to look at myself from
an outside perspective a lot you know
and I just try to be my role model
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because ka attitude
until does the same transfer that do
more profound accent check out the link
in the description you can go and
capture both alpha must know which clips
resonated the most of you was much
needed to take this video and
immediately apply to in life or to
business somehow leave in the comments
below really curious about that what you
have I also want to give a quick shirt
surgically Yama thank you so much dance
brings up a couple of my book here one
word and making that close to putting on
Twitter I really appreciate the support
I hope you enjoyed 3 thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you hope
you teach to believe in yourself and
whatever your wonder is much love
[Music]
when I'm doing something I do it to the
fullest capacitor for this potential
like I want to be one of the greatest
artists of all time I don't just write
to be underground rapper I rap it
because I want to be one of the biggest
one of the greatest ever one of the
greatest influences in the world when it
comes to music you know I'm saying
that's my mission that's my goal
I'm always loved when I challenged
myself to make something different
that's always right and that makes me
happy it makes me proud of my work
because like anytime I post to Mike I'm
trying to create a new sound I ain't
never tryna we make what I already did
you're right saying so ever I love that
that eight I feel like the challenges
for young artists probably comes more
when you're like alright I need to go
beyond throwing down to sixteen I need
to put together a complete record I
don't find it too challenging because
like you know just as an artist is that
you know something that we do it didn't
with me I don't just keep it basic like
I won't just have a normal structured
song like you know a verse hook verse
hook like you know I might just have a
long as verse and then a hook at the end
there's no rule